tu vas faire dodo nous on va regarder du
côté des étoiles maintenant avec alain
cirou vous savez que la terre a été
frôlé par un astéroïde qui est passé à
300 mille kilomètres de distance et
alain sirois rencontré l'astronome qui a
découvert cette catastrophe qui nous
menaçait et qui nous remet menace nous
allons voir pourquoi
ouf il est passé et tout risque de
collision est écarté
l'astéroïde découvert par les astronomes
du cirque à aura en frôlant la terre
fait couler beaucoup d'encre et
réveiller une terreur australe celle de
la mort tombé du ciel
les scientifiques sont ils en mesure de
prévoir un tel risque en effectuant une
surveillance systématique de la voûte
céleste
les astronomes sont certainement les
seuls à pouvoir éventuellement détecter
et prévoir ce type de catastrophe mais
c'est pas sûr qu'on soit toujours
capable de la faire voir et on peut
imaginer que l'objet par exemple que
nous avons découvert il ya quelques
semaines soit arrivé très près la terre
sont qu'on le voit arriver parce qu'il y
avait la même direction que le soleil
alors très bien pu en fait ignorer
totalement sa trajectoire il recevoir
véritable guetteurs du cosmos les
astronomes du cir garçons menacé si la
passion et sans faille
les crédits sont insuffisants et chaque
année la bataille est rude pour que
l'observatoire survivent
alors les scientifiques se transforme en
vulgarisateur et allie art et science
pour expliquer convaincre et illustré
l'objet de leur recherche
les astronomes ont besoin des artistes
pour pouvoir mieux comprendre ce qu'ils
imaginent ils n'ont pas la technique la
femme est en fait de représenter ce qui
sage et travailler avec un peintre comme
jean michel joly ça permet en fait
d'avoir des vraies images du système
solaire bien avant que les cendres
puissent aller les acquérir sur les
planètes elle même dans les jours qui
ont suivi la découverte une peinture du
caillou céleste a été réalisée une façon
originale d'illustrer une découverte
mais surtout une première pour
l'astronomie française qui a bien besoin
d'un soutien populaire pour conserver
les moyens de surveiller les étoiles non
c'est bon